hey guys welcome here to e3 2017 I'm
Justin here with Peter and Nintendo
revealed a whole lot more about probably
one of its most exciting games coming up
Super Mario Odyssey and Peter you got a
chance to play like twenty minutes of it
yeah I got to play two different levels
one of them being new dog city you know
that city we've seen that has humans
next to Mario that are very different
heights do they explain that why are the
humans all different sizes
it's a weird game a lot of it is not
actually explained like you know the
premise is kind of the same you're
trying to rescue Princess Peach from
Bowser but apart from that the game is
just filled with a lot of interesting
new opportunities and possibilities have
never really been seen in a Mario game
before and I was kind of thrown to the
fire so I had to kind of just uh treat
it like a playground well one of those
new things is this hat I every Mario
game introduces some kind of new
mechanic and this one the Hat definitely
seems like a really way out there
different kind of thing yeah like as you
saw during the Nintendo spotlight
presentation the the moment for Mario
Odyssey opens up with a shot I'm a
dinosaur and you don't really know what
this game is until the dinosaur turns
around you realize he's wearing Mario's
hat and then he boosts into Mario yeah
then you kind of start to realize okay
wait a minute you can throw that hat on
the enemies and take over their bodies
so that is the big thing about the Hat
what we've seen up until now is that you
can use it as a platform but as we saw
in as I got to try you know if you see a
Goomba or any other classic Mario an
enemy like one of the bullet bills after
that isn't throw a hat on him and you
can possess that enemy and use their
abilities so you just throw the hat
around it at anything and just become
that how does that work exactly you
throw it on it and you because it does
that feel like it changes the gameplay
significantly is that part of the puzzle
solving yeah I mean so puzzles are weird
because you're basically put in it's
almost like a diorama they were kind of
describing it as like this Japanese art
of creating like small contained spaces
so that's their idea of a sandbox so
it's not like a huge open world sandbox
what you get are these little places
filled with puzzles and these little
moon collectibles that are similar to
stars in previous Mario games but
they're treated like khorog scenes there
are like far too many that you can I
could count looking at the map and so
what you kind of do is you look for
things that catch your interest and then
you try to figure out ways by utilizing
your environment which
whose enemies to get to those things to
collect those those items when you
collect enough of those moon items you
can then use your bazooka hot-air
balloon or blimp to go to a different
one so that's kind of how progression
works and you know that's sort of the
flow of you know puzzle solving as it as
it was and there's not really like
levels to speak up either and there's no
lives well so what happens when you die
you lose some coins so they've compared
it in some ways to Super Mario 64 but it
sounds like that's not quite the right
comparison I think what they're getting
out with the Mario 64 comparison is that
this is a game that is sort of leaving
you to sort of tackle challenges and
like orders that you want to it's not
this very like strict linear path
through set levels or even like a world
map necessarily but also it's a very
hardcore game I mean some of the
challenges I ran into required a lot of
skill to get through them I think you
could look at Super Mario 3d World or 3d
Land and say it was maybe more about
observation than actually performance
and action like you know in a split
second so it's definitely a more
demanding Mario game but it's the
weirdest Mario game I've ever played in
my life I'll tell you that which makes
it just beyond compare to anything else
in the series well I can't wait to try
out more of it myself and for some other
people here on staff to play it and let
all of you guys know what we think
thanks so much for watching it for even
more Nintendo and Mario coverage stay
tuned to game spot calm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]